hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 37 hört zu und spricht nach
das rezept ist einfach das rezept ist
einfach das rezept ist für vier personen
das
selbst ist für vier personen hast du die
zutaten schon eingekauft
hast du die zutaten schon eingekauft
hast du den tisch gedeckt
hast du den tisch gedeckt kochen finde
ich
wir ich kochen finde ich schwierig ich
backe gern kuchen
ich backe gern kuchen kochst du oft
kochst du oft was ist dein
lieblingsessen
was ist dein lieblingsessen
mein lieblingsessen ist pizza mein
lieblingsessen ist pizza sushi isst man
mit stäbchen sushi isst man mit stäbchen
möchtest du ein stück kuchen
ich esse gern gemüse ich esse
gemüse ich mag keinen salat
ich mag keinen salat belegt die pizza
mit käse belegt die pizza mit käse shell
die zwiebeln schälen die zwiebeln wird
mit salz und pfeffer würzen mit salz und
pfeffer ist mit gabel und messer ist mit
gabel und messer für die suppe alle fünf
minuten um für die suppe alle fünf
minuten um back den kuchen für 30
minuten bei 180 grad im ofen
den kuchen für 30 minuten bei 180 grad
im ofen raffler die karotten pavle die
karotten gießt die suppe in eine
schüssel gießt die suppe in eine
schüssel gibt nun den rest der zutaten
in die pfanne gibt nun
rest der zutaten in die pfanne schneide
den fisch in portionen schneide den
fisch in portionen richte das essen auf
dem teller an richte das essen auf dem
teller an
servier die suppe heiß serviert die
suppe heiß dass die teigwaren 10 minuten
kochen
lasst die teigwaren 10 minuten kochen
nimm ein messer nimm ein messer schlag
die eier auf schlag die eier auf
den teig aus weil den teig aus koch die
kartoffeln koch die kartoffeln
die gurke in würfel schneiden die gurke
in würfel wascht im salat
entschuldigung ich kann die suppe nicht
dessen entschuldigung ich kann die suppe
nicht essen
die suppe ist zum salz in die suppe ist
zusatz ich das essen ist mir zu scharf
das essen ist mir zu scharf gib mir
bitte salz und pfeffer
die soße ist zufahrt gibt mir
salz und pfeffer die soße ist sofort die
pommes frites sind zu fettig die boncred
sind so fettig die zitrone ist sauer
die zitrone ist sauer
der kaffee ist bitter der kaffee ist
bitter die torte ist süß die torte ist
süß
wie schmeckt das essen
es schmeckt sehr gut danke es schmeckt
sehr gut danke
mama
mir ist langweilig möchtest du mir beim
kochen helfen
möchtest du mir beim kochen helfen
oh ja was soll ich machen oh ja was soll
ich machen
geh schnell in den keller und hole 2
zwiebeln gut geht schnell in den keller
und hole 2 zwiebeln
hier sind die zwiebeln was soll ich
jetzt machen
jetzt machen was dir jetzt die hände
okay was dir jetzt die hände
ich habe meine hände gewaschen
ich habe meine hände gewaschen gut
schneidet jetzt die zwiebeln in kleine
stücke gut schneidet jetzt die zwiebeln
in kleine stücke ich bin schon fertig
mami was kann ich jetzt machen
ich bin schon fertig mami was kann ich
jetzt machen
bring mir die geschnittenen zwiebeln
bring mir die geschnittenen zwiebeln gib
sie hier in die pfanne
juhu das macht spaß gib sie hier in die
pfanne
juhu das macht spaß sehr gut kannst du
noch etwas für mich machen sehr gut
kannst du noch etwas für mich machen ja
was mama
rom bittet die abwasch maschine aus rom
bittet die abwasch maschine aus
[Musik]